Norway is one of the most unique, incredible,...
...rugged countries in the whole world.
The first location is the Nigardsbreen Glacier.
This glacier lies about 19 miles north of the village Gaupne.
The Nigardsbreen Glacier...
...is actually an arm of the largest glacier in Continental Europe...
...called the Jostedalsbreen Glacier.
To get to the glacier, a small boat will transport you to the base...
...where you'll cross the palest,  most turquoise blue glacier water...
...you have ever seen in your whole life.
From the forest to the base of the glacier,...
...you have about a 30-minute hike.
Once you get to the base of the glacier,...
...you're kitted out with crampons and ice picks and a harness.
It is impossible to climb ice without crampons...
...and they actually come with the guide...
...and I'll have all that information down below.
Once you start climbing,...
...it's about eight hours in total from the top to the bottom.
This glacier hike was one of, if not,...
...the most defining travel experience I've had in my whole life.
It's one thing to see it,...
...but to actually hear the pieces of ice the size of buildings...
...moving and breaking and it felt like a living thing,...
...this massive, massive, living thing.